ces dernières années on a beaucoup parlé
du déclin des abeilles à travers le
monde des risques s'implique également
mais il n'ya pas que les populations
d'abeilles qui s'effondre et ça j'ai
appris ça grâce à renault il ya beaucoup
d'autres insectes qui sont en train de
disparaître
on va vous parler d'une toute nouvelle
étude qui dit qu'on pourrait voir 40%
des insectes de la planète disparaître
donc renault malgré en gagne est avec
moi pour sa chronique scientifique du
samedi vont jour renault mais bonjour
oui donc vraiment c'est tout signal de
larmes de la par les chercheurs
disons que c'est une étude assez
pessimiste mais elle est très important
parce que c'est une des premières
méta-analyse à s'être penché sur la
question
donc les chercheurs ont compilé les
données de 73 grandes études qui ont été
faites au cours des 40 dernières années
dont les informations viennent d'un peu
partout sur terre et ce qu'ils ont
observé c'est que les insectes
disparaissent en rythme huit fois plus
rapide que toutes les autres espèces de
vertébrés
ils ont aussi calculé que chaque année
on perd deux points 5 % de la biomasse
totale des insectes sur ces deux points
5 % du poids total de tous les insectes
sur terre qui disparaît chaque année et
cette baisse elle est constante depuis
les 30 dernières années donc ça ça veut
dire que on va perdre jusqu'à peut-être
40 % des espèces d'insectes et au cours
des prochaines décennies est ce qu'on
parle ici de toutes les espèces
d'insectes mais exact est sûr que il ya
certaines espèces qui sont plus à risque
d'autres par exemple les plus touchés on
retrouve les coléoptères on retrouve les
grandes familles qui comporte les
abeilles les papillons où les fourmis et
on trouve ça touche aussi beaucoup les
espèces aquatiques comme les libellules
par exemple mais est ce que les
chercheurs ont remarqué c'est que c'est
pas juste les insectes qui ont des
niches très spécialisés qui ont des
besoins vraiment précis qui risque de
disparaître
même les grandes espèces généralistes
qui général qui sont censés s'habituer à
tout laisse toutes les situations mais
elles aussi sont en train de décliner
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
touche tous les écosystèmes
oui parce qu'on fait le lien direct avec
l'activité humaine oui ils sont là ils
font le lien avec plusieurs activités
humaines en fait parce que pas un seul
coupable dans cette situation là c'est
quelque chose de très complexe
ils ont identifié quatre grands
responsables dans leurs dans leurs
travaux le premier c'est la destruction
de l'habitat des insectes donc on parle
de l'urbanisation la déforestation et de
l'agriculture intensive
il y aura ensuite la pollution donc les
la pollution qui est surtout agricoles
dont le relâchement dans l'environnement
de certains pesticides de fertilisants
ou des herbicides comme le glyphosate
par exemple et ensuite d'autres formes
de vie donc les espèces invasives des
parasites ou des nouvelles maladies et
finalement il ya les changements
climatiques
mais ces quatre grands facteurs là ils
n'agissent pas toutes de la même manière
partout sur terre en même temps par
exemple de ce que les chercheurs ont vu
c'est qu'en amérique du sud le plus gros
problème c'est la déforestation et les
changements climatiques
alors qu'en amérique du nord et en
europe baissent et l'urbanisation et
l'intensification de l'agriculture met
ensemble à ce que les auteurs calcul
c'est que la plus grosse part du
problème ça reste notre façon de
produire de la nourriture
ah oui ça peut être quoi les
conséquences de sa baisse et ils vont en
avoir plusieurs c'est sûr que les plus
la plus importante
le plus évident souci c'est les concessi
les effets que ça rassure le reste la
chaîne alimentaire
beaucoup d'espèces animales qui
dépendent des insectes pour se nourrir
75 % des plantes en ont besoin pour leur
pollinisation et vu que les insectes ça
représente le deux tiers des espèces
vivantes sur terre
mais si elles sont en déclin en général
mais ça peut avoir des conséquences
catastrophiques sur tout le reste
les chercheurs ont aussi remarqué une
conséquence un peu plus surprenante
parce que c'est pour certains insectes
qui ont tendance à se reproduire très
rapidement on pourrait bénéficier de la
disparition des autres espèces il
pourrait en profiter pour prendre leur
place
malheureusement c'est pas les plus le
cpo les plus plaisantes donc dix au
cours des prochaines décennies ont
presque retrouvé avec plus de mouches
plus de coquerelles et beaucoup d'autres
insectes qui les des insectes nuisibles
qui se sont habitués à vivre à proximité
des humains on pourrait en profiter de
cette situation le groupe il est ce que
c'est c'est unanime à ce que tous les
chercheurs sont d'accord avec ses
conclusions c'est sûr qu'il faut les
tempérer un peu ses résultats parce que
les insectes c'est parmi les populations
animales les moins connus sur terre donc
les données sur le déclin des
populations d'insectes mais les données
les grandes études qui mesure sa selle
qui viennent d'europe et d'amérique du
nord est sont fiables mais il y en a un
peu moins en ce qui concerne les i
l'amérique du sud où l'afrique donc le
dessin déclin qui est difficile à
mesurer mais même si le côté à la remise
de l'étude a été critiquée par certains
chercheurs tous sont d'accord que cette
première étude la série mondiale c'est
une signal d'alarmé dans le fond et
qu'il faut vraiment commencer à
surveiller toutes les populations
d'insectes votre caddie qu'on va pouvoir
la revoir sur la page facebook de rdi
matin merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
bonne journée mois